ANJALI SASTRY: I've been
teaching at MIT since 2001.
And I've taught all
kinds of classes.
But the innovation I'm excited
to be talking about today is
a new set of linked projects
that I helped our mid-career
executive students--
the Sloan Fellow MBAs--
on this past year.
So I hung up my
shingle and asked
students who had a passion
for linking technology
with social impact in some
way to come and talk to me.
And I created with
them a set of projects
which allowed the students to
really dig into areas that they
came to MIT passionate
about, but also
to link it to their coursework
and their degree program.
SARAH HANSEN: Could
you talk a little bit
about some of the specific
projects that students did?
ANJALI SASTRY: The
project students
did ranged greatly
but all had as a theme
using what they
were learning here
and tapping into emerging or
existing technology in new ways
to find solutions to
problems that face many.
That's the social
impact aspect of it.
And it took with each
student some effort
to really map out a good enough
and focused enough question
that was doable as
an independent study
project and that was deep enough
to allow me to really bring
to bear the educational goals
that I had for the projects.
So one student,
Doreen, was really
interested in the problem of
creating agricultural products
in Africa using crops
and products that are
grown right there in Africa.
Why is Africa importing a
lot of consumer products
when the continent has a
lot of agricultural assets?
So she was really interested
in understanding--
what are the business models,
what are the constraints, what
are the opportunities
when it comes to finding
new ways to create locally
sourced products that could
actually serve
beauty, nutrition,
or other needs in
her native Zimbabwe
or elsewhere in Africa.
I'll tell you about
another project.
Idoia, a student who came
to me after deep experience
at the World Bank, was really
interested in a challenge
that traditional governmental
organizations really
wrestle with.
How do we tap into
entrepreneurship
when we're trying to
serve the public good?
There seems to be a challenge
in linking the entrepreneur
and the public sector.
And we know that there are
all kinds of innovations
that play in this sphere.
From ridesharing and
regulated industries,
all the way through to providing
in a better way the services
that governments are
already on the hook for.
So they're either
regulated or they
are substitutes for
improvements of services
that governments provide.
And sometimes they're
also missing services.
What are the barriers to this?
Where are the opportunities?
What are the trends?
And can we actually
map out where
we think this field could go,
of mixing entrepreneurship
and the public sector?
One of my students, Aline,
came to MIT completely on fire
with this idea of tapping
into analytics and AI
to solve what she saw
as a major challenge
when it came to bringing finance
to small holder and small scale
farmers.
She's an expert on
agricultural finance.
And she realized that, in her
native Brazil and elsewhere,
people who didn't have good
credit standing and good credit
records--
farmers who didn't
have those assets--
couldn't get loans and
were forever locked out.
So there's a big dichotomy
between the people who have
access to finance
and those who don't.
Could she break down
that barrier in some way?
Could new forms of data and
technology help do that?
So instead of relying only
on somebody's credit record,
could you look at the weather,
their farming choices,
their behaviors,
and physical data,
and use it to come
up with a better
assessment of the riskiness of
a given farmer from the lender's
point of view?
Slightly technical area.
But it actually has
huge implications
because it could open the
door to all kinds of folks
who are excluded from
traditional finance
by providing other
methods of sorting out
their riskiness and
their credit worthiness.
SARAH HANSEN: So how did
it all work logistically?
How did you manage to create
all these different individual
projects?
ANJALI SASTRY: So that's the
downside of this approach.
Each project was customized.
It's kind of a boutique
learning experience in a sense.
And one of the
things I've learned
about trying to innovate
when it comes to teaching
is you have to be
willing to invest
a lot the first few rounds--
the first few years
you do something.
And then over
time, you learn how
to make it a little more
efficient, streamlined,
and maybe scalable, and
more cost effective.
But this year was
definitely a labor of love.
So students came to me
with all kinds of ideas.
And I had open office hours.
I have a wiki page
where students
can sign up to meet with
me in 20 minute increments.
And I would just set up hours
of these meetings every week
and sit and talk to
students about their ideas,
try to formulate some
reasonable next steps,
really push them to
think about how they're
using their coursework here
and their presence on campus
to craft something they
couldn't do anywhere else
and that spoke to
everything else
they had access to
while they were here.
So that process took a
lot of back and forth.
Usually, I would meet
with students once a week.
I opened a shared
folder with each of them
and would shoot materials
that I found into the folder
and have them load their drafts,
work plans, and other work
in progress there.
And then I also got
into a very quick habit
of sending any interesting
reading, news article,
conference notice
directly to the students.
So some of them would be getting
10 emails from me a week.
But that really got
us going because they
could see I was thinking about
it all week, and they were too.
I learned I had to keep a
whiteboard up in my office with
each project and each person,
because I had over a dozen
running, to keep them straight
and try to remember who's doing
what so that when I saw it--
when I came into the office--
that person would be on
my mind, or that project
would be on my mind.
SARAH HANSEN: Do you
see this as something
that is potentially
scalable in the future?
ANJALI SASTRY: I do.
One question I've been
thinking about a lot
is how you could also use peers.
Could we craft project clusters?
So could we link the themes?
But could we also have students
helping each other, coaching
each other a little bit?
Could we use group meetings
as a way to surface a helpful
discussion about what's
working and what isn't?
I think that that's
the next step.
So I think that will
get to some scalability.
I do think-- mundane
as it sounds--
I think it's also important to
have good forms and paperwork.
Having people really
articulate in writing briefly
what they want to do and having
a structured kind of update
process really helps.
Keep the momentum,
and build the focus.
SARAH HANSEN: How do you measure
success in projects like this?
ANJALI SASTRY: That's
a great question
because students who are
following their passions really
get into it.
You give them enough freedom,
they will have a good time.
But part of our challenge
as their teachers
is to help make sure that we're
embedding into their approach
enough rigor, that we're looking
at the data and the evidence,
and that it's being linked
to the content we're
teaching here.
So a passion project by itself
may or may not be academic.
So there's a bit
of tension there
of us having to remind students
of the need to keep making
all of these connections.
So I would really
view success as when
we're able to get the students
to not only pull out, develop,
polish a great new idea, but
also to link it to what they've
been learning here and test
their ideas with a level
of attention to the data--
even if it's qualitative--
that really we can
all stand behind.
SARAH HANSEN: And how did you
do that in these projects?
ANJALI SASTRY: So part
of the requirement
is to really make sure
that if a student--
there's actually
quite a lot of work
in trying to unpack the logic,
the thinking behind a new idea.
And I would spend a lot of
time trying to help figure out,
where is it we need to drill
down to backup this idea?
Where is it that we use the
literature and the research,
where you're going to do
desk research to shore up
one leg of what you're doing?
And where is it
that you're going
to gather new information--
whether it's by observation, by
interviews, by other methods--
that you can bring to bear?
So I really was
looking for both.
Where's the link to other
people's work to the research
and the literature?
Where's the link to
something new that you've
uncovered using methods
that you were going
to describe systematically?
SARAH HANSEN: I see.
ANJALI SASTRY: The
great thing about this
is that it helps me to learn.
So part of what I think the
huge value in teaching this way
is that you, as the
instructor, have
this gift of hearing new
ideas that aren't necessarily
embedded into the
academic structure yet.
So I discovered there
really is a need
to build a better
theory and framework
around public entrepreneurship.
That's really interesting.
That helps me think about
my own research goals
and where I might build
new collaborations here
on campus with other
faculty and researchers.
SARAH HANSEN: And speaking
of collaborations,
what was the role of networking
in this experience for Fellows?
ANJALI SASTRY: So
students coming here
have varying predilections
for networking
and connecting with others.
And many of them really benefit
from having a focus to that.
So very often we
tell students-- you
have this gift of being
here on campus for a while.
Make the most of it.
But if you're just
trying to meet
people to fill up your Rolodex,
it's rather self-serving.
And it's awkward.
And there's no reason to meet.
But if you can articulate a
really interesting question,
this gives students a
reason to contact people.
So I really view
the two as linked.
Develop a great problem
statement or research question.
Use that to look at what you
have access to on campus.
That might include faculty,
postdocs, research teams.
That might include alumni.
It includes folks within
the MIT ecosystems.
You might head over to an
incubator or some other--
a venue, an event
where people are.
And then because we get a lot
of people passing through--
as well as invitations
to meetings, conferences,
and events, globally--
I would shoot those
to my students.
So say, so-and-so is
coming to campus next week.
See if you can get
on their agenda.
And that would often work.
SARAH HANSEN: How
are you looking
to tweak this experience
the next time you teach it?
ANJALI SASTRY: So I
think having the steps
in the process a
little bit clearer
and having the motivating
question of each step
in a project like this--
really central.
So early stages, here's what
you should be thinking about.
Here's the questions
you need to answer.
Middle stages, late-- so if
I have a better framework
for the steps in
the work, I think
that would be a big benefit.
Another is to realize not
every student who comes in
with their passion project is
necessarily going to want to--
or should-- turn it
into an in-depth study.
So I've learned that you
can't convert everyone.
And that's OK.
Because this is an offering
of a new learning experience.
It's very much driven by
the students' interest.
You need to really
be able to allow
the students to self select in.
It's hard to offer something
like this as a requirement.
So that's another piece is
striking the right balance
between opening the
door and inviting people
in versus cracking the whip
and following up on them.
Students get really busy.
So one downside of an
unstructured course
is that it can
fall by the wayside
because they have their
structured requirements
and course meetings for all
their other classes and this
begins to feel like
something on the side.
So how you maintain the
momentum and make sure
that enough investment is
going in is really important.
So better sourcing
and screening.
Better process.
And having regular
meetings are all really
important ingredients.
SARAH HANSEN: Is
there anything else
you'd like to share
about facilitating
an experience like this that
we haven't touched on yet?
ANJALI SASTRY: I think
one of the challenges
that an instructor
has to balance
is, how far am I
willing to go outside
of my domain of expertise?
How much do I know
about the blockchain?
That's not an area
of my research.
So how far do I want to
go down a set of projects
that take that on.
I need to be able to
figure it out for myself
and then also be very
clear with the students.
I'm interested in this topic.
I'll learn with you.
But my domain of expertise
relates to these areas.
We can apply it
to your questions.
We can apply systems thinking,
or organizational change,
or business models to the
questions you're articulating.
But I am not the technical
expert on this domain.
So you'll need to work
with someone else on that.
And different instructors
have different interests
in stepping out of
their comfort zone.
So I think that's
really important.
Another big question
is, how willing are you
as an instructor to have a
mishmash of projects that
take on very different domains?
Or would you like them to be
geographically or thematically
linked?
I suspect that I'm going
to evolve a little more
towards clustered projects.
And I've seen some
of my colleagues
use such clusters of
projects over time
to build their own
research insights.
So I think that's
really exciting.
The idea of encouraging
students to take
on projects that motivate
them but that also speak
to an ongoing research
program and on which you
can start to build more
knowledge and evidence.
SARAH HANSEN: Do
you have any words
of advice to your colleagues
out in the world who might
want to try something similar?
ANJALI SASTRY: Teaching this
way is incredibly rewarding
and also really scary.
You'll often be invited
into domains where
you don't have the expertise.
And it's quite
hard to predict how
a given session or a
conversation will go.
It's not like running a case
where you know the story
and you know what you're going
to say at each moment in class,
or you at least
got a sense of what
that might look like because
very often students will
come in and say, I've
totally changed my mind.
And you have to deal with that.
So there's both the
personal journey
of learning that's
less predictable
and the domain part
that's less predictable.
But you, as the
instructor, get to set
some of those parameters.
By, for instance,
requiring a written update
before a meeting, you can
manage the conversation better.
And by specifying
the types of projects
that you would really
want to take on,
you can also ensure
that they're clustered
in areas that are relevant
to your own expertise.
For me, one of the challenges--
I have to tell
you-- is branding.
What do I call this?
Is it something
different than just doing
a bunch of independent studies?
I think it's a work in progress.
So I think the
first few times you
try out something like
this, it doesn't yet
have a fully distinct identity.
And then, as I
hone it, I'm going
to give it a clearer name.
But I've been using terms
that link to social impact,
that link to technology,
and that also frame--
perhaps because it's
focusing on the students
I'm teaching-- but the idea
of thinking strategically,
thinking as a leader,
and really putting
yourselves in the shoes of an
entrepreneur or an executive.
So I want them to not simply
make general arguments
about what should
happen, but to think
about what they could do as
a leader, an entrepreneur,
an executive.
So, yeah, come up
with a great name.
I'm still working on mine.
All suggestions are welcome.
I put in there terms
like new executive
thinking for social impact or
technology for social impact.
So we'll see how that plays out.
Check back later.
SARAH HANSEN: Thank you so much.
ANJALI SASTRY: Sure.
You're welcome.